The real life exploits of Leonidas of Sparta
and his 300 warriors at Thermoplyae have given
rise to the myth of the Spartan superhero
– the supremely disciplined man of few words
who had a body of steel, could endure any
hardship and would fight to his last breath.
Such men really did exist and chief among
them was Leonidas, the Spartan king who defied
the might of Persia, saving Greece from annihilation.
In this week’s Biographics we discover the
real life Leonidas.
Early Years
Leonidas was born around 540 BCE in the Greek
city of Sparta.
At that time Greece was made up of hundreds
of city states, of which Athens and Sparta
were the largest.
Leonidas’ father, Anaxandrides, was the
king of Sparta.
For the Greeks, warfare was the supreme statement
of a citizen.
It is what made a man and gave him the right
to be a part of his city.
Every Greek, in every city state was obliged
to military service from the age of twenty
until the age of forty-five.
In order to prepare for that life, boys were
put into a military training camp, known as
the Agoge, from the age of seven.
There was only exception to this compulsory
military training – the first-born son of
the king of each city state.
His upbringing would be focused on grooming
him for the power that he would inherit on
his father’s death.
Leonidas, however, was the third son of Anaxandrides.
His older half-brother, Cleomenes I was first
in line to be the next king of Sparta.
As a result, Leonidas spent his formative
years learning how to become a Spartan warrior.
Between the age of seven and twelve, Leonidas
underwent a training regimen, along with a
group of other boys, under the supervision
of a warden who was called the paidonomos,
which literally translates to ‘herder of
boys.’
This was a highly respected Spartan, drawn
from the highest social class.
His authority allowed him to punish any who
misbehaved, and to this end he was accompanied
by a whip wielding squad of youths who were
ready to eagerly mete out his punishments.
As the system was designed to produce effective
warriors, great emphasis was placed on a rough
and tumble lifestyle.
The boys were divided into bands and they
chose as their leader the best fighter.
Meanwhile the paidonomos would keep a close
eye on their antics, meting out punishment
to any who got out of line.
Spartan boys in the Agoge were not permitted
to wear shoes.
It was believed that leaping, jumping and
running were accomplished more swiftly barefoot.
The boys were also allowed just one cloak
throughout the year.
This was designed to force them to grow accustomed
to sweltering summers and freezing winters,
making do with what little covering they had.
Food for the boys was strictly rationed, on
the belief that a lean, hungry man fights
far more effectively than a fat, satiated
one.
Also, being able to go a long time without
food would make for a better prepared warrior.
Theft was severely punished – unless it
involved the stealing of food.
The logic behind this was that by learning
to pilfer food the boys would be practicing
the skills of foraging that would be needed
when on military campaign.
As well as their training to become warriors,
the boys were also taught to read and write.
In fact, the Spartans gained a reputation
as men of learning, who loved music, poetry
and dance.
The age of twelve was a watershed year in
the life of a young Spartan.
He was now placed in a band of about a dozen
of his peers, to live under the headship of
one drawn from his ranks, the eiren, or prefect.
The one chosen was the smartest, the most
battle ready and cunning.
Though there is no record that Leonidas was
put in this position, it is quite likely that
he, being the son of the king and given the
future battle prowess that he displayed, did
indeed serve as an eiren during his teen years.
The other boys had to give their absolute
obedience to the eiren.
They were to act as his servants, collecting
firewood and fetching vegetables using their
thieving skills.
Also, at the age of twelve, Spartan boys were
taken under the wing of an erastes, or ‘admirer’,
to receive a form of mentoring.
Whereas in other Grecian city states this
relationship was a sexual one, this was not
the case in Sparta.
Desire for the body rather than the soul of
a boy was considered to be the height of shame.
At the age of eighteen, the Spartan youth
became a melleiren, a title which means ‘nearly
an eiren’.
His military training was now stepped up as
he came close to entering military service.
And so, by the age of twenty, Spartan society
had moulded Leonidas into an agile, battle-ready
military machine, full of self-confidence,
discipline and a killer instinct.
He was ready to make his mark on the field
of battle.
Leonidas had trained to be a hoplite warrior.
Hoplites were experts in using the short iron
sword and round shield and spear.
They fought in tight phalanx formation in
which they would approach the enemy with shield
overheads to form a tortoise-shell like defence
to the oncoming barrage of arrows.
Just as Leonidas was about to enter military
service, news reached him that his father,
the King, had died.
His brother, Cleomenes I now inherited the
throne.
So, while one brother took on the mantle of
supreme rulership over the city-sate, the
other inherited the role that he had given
his entire life to – that of a Spartan warrior.
The Spartans army was divided into age groups,
spanning ten years.
Within these divisions, the basic grouping
of men was into mess groups of about fifteen
men.
It was with these men that Leonidas lived
during his twenties.
It was also around this time that Leonidas
married the daughter of his half-brother Cleomones.
She was named Gorgo and was by all accounts
a beautiful and politically astute woman.
Leonidas’ older half-brother, Cleomones.
Over the last three years, Grecian city states
had, one by one, succumbed to the invading
Persians.
The capitulation of these powers was a source
of outrage to the proud Spartan king and,
in 491, he attempted to overthrow a neighbouring
king who was about to concede to the Persians.
But when their king’s plans to oust a duly
appointed fellow king was revealed, the people
of Sparta were not happy and Cleomones was
forced to flee the city.
He then set about gathering a formidable army
in the surrounding territories.
Wisely, the Spartans allowed him to return
but, believing that their king had gone insane,
had him thrown into chains.
Apparently, this order was carried out on
the directions of Leonidas.
Cleomones was placed under the guard of the
Helot slave class.
The imprisoned king managed to persuade one
of his captors to lend him his dagger.
With that he apparently committed an appalling
sort of hari-kari, slicing himself into pieces
from his feet upward.
When Cleomones had taken the throne thirty
years previously, his half-brother Dorieus,
who was older than Leonidas, was incensed
that the throne had passed him by.
Finding it impossible to remain in Sparta,
he attempted to establish a colony in Africa.
When this failed, he went to Sicily where
he met an untimely death.
So, it was that, on the death of Cleomones
in 490, Leonidas was next in line for the
throne.
The Persian Threat
Immediately upon ascending the throne, Leonidas
was thrown into the heat of conflict.
For years the Persians had been threatening
Greece and now, the situation was at a critical
point.
Swift action was needed – and Leonidas proved
to be the right man to deliver it.
The goal of the Persians was the absolute
subjection of Greece.
They already ruled over a number of Greek
cities on the coast of Asia.
The continued existence of other Greek city
states was a beacon of light for those already
engulfed by the Persians, making them dream
of independence.
This was not acceptable to Persian king Xerxes.
To crush all Grecian resistance, Xerxes has
gathered together a massive force, consisting
of 1207 warships, and as many as 1, 700,000
warriors.
In stark contrast, the Greeks were badly disunited.
Of more than one hundred city states, only
31 had agreed to stand and fight against the
Persians.
The kings of these 31 states met and swore
an oath to fight the Persians and to punish
any cities that went over to the Persian side.
Still, with the key states of Thessaly and
Boiotia supporting Persia, there was no active
resistance to the invaders right down to the
city of Athens.
The Spartans had taken on the mantle of leadership
in the resistance.
The city was recognised as being in a position
of moral, political and, above all, military
pre-eminence in all of Greece.
Under Leonidas, the Spartans were absolutely
determined to fight, to conquer or to die.
The alliance with other resisting city-states
allowed Leonidas to put around 60,000 men
into the field.
King Xerxes of Persia believed that his overwhelming
superiority in numbers would guarantee the
victory.
It was his strategy to keep his naval fleet
and his infantry closely connected.
The infantry thus marched along the shore
and the Persians even dug a canal through
Mount Athos to allow the ships to stay close
when the army got inland.
By August 18th, 480, Xerxes had overrun Macedonia,
and Thessaly.
His army had now arrived at the place called
Thermopylae, a narrow pass between Thessaly
and the ocean.
Leonidas knew that he could never defeat the
entire Persian army.
But he believed that if he could inflict a
devastating blow of such magnitude that it
decimated a portion of that army, the psychological
damage would be such that the Persians would
withdraw.
But not everyone was convinced that this strategy
would work.
Undermining Leonidas’ strategy was the oracle
of Apollo at Delphi, who was considered to
have a hotline to the Gods of Greece.
When the Spartans had approached the Oracle
asking whether they should resist the Persians
the reply that came back was . . .
Either the king of Sparta must die or the
Spartans themselves must be conquered, for
nothing can stand before the might of the
Persian king.
Each successive city state that approached
the Oracle was likewise given a premonition
of doom.
Still, Leonidas was not deterred.
He, and every Spartan warrior with him, would
give his last breath to keep the Persians
out of their beloved city-state.
Leonidas did want to meet the overwhelming
Persian force on the open field.
It was his intention to withdraw to the spot
where the Peloponnesian Peninsula joins the
land of Attica.
This was a very narrow strip of land just
a mile and a half long.
Here he would set his men to building a defensive
wall behind which they would fight Xerxes’
army.
The problem with this plan was that it left
Athens completed without any protection.
So, against his better judgement, Leonidas
agreed to take a small force up to Thermopylae
and to engage the Persians at the narrowest
point of the pass.
would be selected for the defence of Thermopylae
– and they would be led by he himself.
Why were just 300 chosen and why these particular
300?
Firstly 300 was a manageable number for an
elite taskforce.
Secondly the figure 300 had strong symbolic
and practical overtones in Sparta, as it was
the fixed number of the regular royal bodyguard.
The bodyguards were known as the hippeis meaning
cavalrymen, though in fact they served as
infantrymen in the dead centre of the hoplite
phalanx, where the commanding king would be
stationed.
The three hundred hippeis were especially
selected in an intense completion from among
men in the ten youngest adult citizen year-classes,
aged between twenty and twenty-nine.
Leonidas’ Thermopylae advance guard of 300,
however, was to be selected with one crucial
additional criterion.
Besides being exceptionally brave, skilful
and patriotic, each of the chosen few must
also have a living son.
This would ensure that a son would be in place
to carry on his father’s name.
These heirs would then constitute an elite
within an elite, bursting with pride to emulate
the feat of their late fathers.
In addition to the three hundred Spartans,
Leonidas took around 4,000 Peloponnesians
and around a thousand non-combatant Helots.
It is clear that the Thermopylae 300 were
to be, in effect, a suicide squad.
The pass at Thermopylae had a flat plain in
front of it, and that was where the Persians
were encamped.
The pass through the mountains to the sea
was only six feet wide at points.
At the point where the pass widened to fifty
feet, the Spartans set about repairing an
existing wall and making it a much more defensible
location.
After Xerxe’s vast Persian forces arrived
at the pass’ western end, a three of four
days’ delay occurred before he launched
his assault.
In this pre battle pause, it is reported that
Xerxes sent a message to Leonidas, demanding
that he hand over his arms.
The Spartan King replied in just two words
– Molon Labe!
“Come and get them yourself!”
It was also during this lull before the storm
that Persian advance reconnaissance reported
back to Xerxes the strange behaviour they
saw among the Spartans.
Rather than being anxious of the coming attack,
the Greek warriors appeared supremely at ease.
They busied themselves with bathing, braiding
one another’s hair and dancing.
The Persians interpreted this as signs of
fear induced madness until a traitorous Greek
in their midst informed the king that the
Spartans were not mad.
What the Persian spies had seen were the actions
of proud heroes preparing themselves for their
final life and death struggle.
The person king first sent in the Medes, a
force of about two thousand.
But these forces proved no match for the Spartans.
They wore neither helmets nor greaves and
their shields were made of wickerwork.
In the confined spaces of the pass, they were
unable to take advantage of their superiority
in numbers.
When the Medes unleashed a hail of arrows
on the defenders, in unison the Spartans lifted
their shields overhead to form a defensive
roof over their heads.
The Medes and the ranks of troops that followed
them did the best they possibly could under
the judgemental eye of their king.
But it was not enough, and they suffered heavy
losses.
In fact, losses were so great that, on three
occasions, Xerxes is said to have leapt up
in horror from his specially constructed throne,
appalled at the carnage and slaughter of some
of his best men.
From behind the protection of the refurbished
Phaeacian wall Leonidas’ men resisted by
fighting in relays.
This clever tactic maximized the efficient
output of their limited resources and energies.
Leonidas also managed to pull off a series
of feigned retreats followed by a sudden about
turn, then a murderous onslaught on their
overconfident and distorted pursuers.
Eventually, towards the end of daylight, Xerxes
felt that he had no option but to send in
his elite royal bodyguard, the ten thousand
Immortals, under the command of Hydarnes.
But, once again the attack was to no avail
– and it came at the cost of serious casualties.
The gore and bloodshed that engorged the narrow
mountain pass was overwhelming.
The piles of quickly rotting corpses mounted,
the flies swarmed and the stench was palpable.
The battle raged into a second day, and still
Xerxes was unable to make a breakthrough.
By now some 20,000 Persians had fallen to
the Greek resistance and the demoralizing
effect on the remains of the Persian army
was telling – why could they not turn back
these few rebels?
Betrayal and Death
With his frustration at boiling point Xerxes
finally received his break, not through his
military superiority but by means of a traitor.
Xerxes was approached by a Greek turn-coat
by the name of Ephialtes from the city of
Malis who was very familiar with the paths
crossing the mountain range.
He told the king of another path through the
mountain that would allow the Persians to
bypass the Greek defensive position.
Ephialtes offered to escort as many as 10,000
Persian troops through that path by night
and turn the flank of the Spartans.
The Spartans knew of the existence of this
alternative route, but they didn’t know
that Xerxes knew about it.
Xerxes gave this special mission to members
of the royal guard of Immortals, and led by
Ephialtes, they set out in silence at nightfall,
aided by a full moon.
After a heroic climb through the Anopaea mountain
range, up to 1,000 metres, they easily brushed
off and bypassed the thousand Phaeacian guards
posted by Leonidas.
These troops were ill-prepared and were taken
completely by surprise.
Leonidas has long been blamed for not posting
a stronger reinforcement of the Anopea path.
By the morning of day 3 of the conflict, the
Persians had the Greeks outflanked.
Leonidas was now in a pincer grip, caught
from the rear as well as the front.
It is at this point that Leonidas, having
recognized the hopelessness of the situation,
gathered his forces together and ordered all
of the troops, except the Spartans, to make
their escape.
Their cities would need them to fight another
day.
But the Spartans were to make their last stand
there at Thermopylae.
All melted away, except for a group of about
four hundred from Thesbes.
When asked by the king why they, too, did
not go, they replied that they have stayed
because the Spartans have stayed.
They would die with them.
The Greeks made their last stand mostly outside
the Middle Gate wall, enabling them to close
directly with the oncoming enemy.
Leonidas showed himself a true Spartan by
the words with which allegedly ordered his
men to take their early morning meal before
the final encounter . . .
This evening, we shall dine in Hades.
The Spartans sold their souls at a heavy cost.
The Persian losses at the beginning of Day
3 were reportedly heavier even than those
sustained on the previous two days.
The Greeks, depleted though their numbers
were, repeatedly drove the Persians back.
Then, inevitably, the 10, 000 of the Persian
Royal Guard of Immortals emerged from the
rear.
Leonidas fought and died like a man possessed.
When his word shattered after one too many
death blows, he used his hands and mouth to
inflict injury upon the enemy.
The exact manner of his death is unrecorded,
but we do know that, as soon as he fell, the
Persians took hold of the body and tried to
drag it away.
Seeing this, the Spartans leapt on their king
and attempted to pull him back.
Four times the body of Leonidas was dragged
away before the remnant of the Spartan defenders
got full possession of it and formed a defensive
circle around it.
In this position, with their spears and lances
broken, their bodies battered and bloodied,
and their dead king in their midst, the Spartans
resorted to throwing rocks at the surrounding
force of Persians.
Finally, a massive hail of arrows was launched
and the last Spartans were cut down.
Perhaps the greatest testament to the effectiveness
of the heroic defence which Leonidas had affected
against the Persians was the treatment of
his corpse by Xerxes.
The Spartan king was decapitated and his body
was crucified.
Xerxes then went about trying to hide the
true number of casualties that his men had
suffered.
But the great defence by the Spartans could
not be hidden from history.
The deaths of Leonidas and his fellow Spartans
greatly lifted Greek morale.
And the vital period that the Spartans had
held up the Persian advance gave time for
the Athenian Greek fleet to wreak havoc on
the Persian navy and eventually led to the
defeat of the Persian threat.
So, by giving his life so dearly at Thermopylae,
Leonidas became the saviour
of his people.